a lot of people especially younger guys
are living out the life that their
father their cousin their brother
whatever has projected onto them or what
they think that person wants them to do
the only thing that was able to get me
out of that rut because I felt like I
hated the life I was going to live but I
felt like I couldn't get out of it
because I thought I was going to let
everyone down and it only got to the
point where I said this statement I
either have to die in their eyes or die
in my own I picked dying in their eyes
so that I could live my life and that
was in my opinion when I actually became
a man because it stopped being about
pleasing my father but pleasing myself
that is the ultimate position of power